you
a record number of icebergs in Canada's
so-called Iceberg Alley is forcing cargo
ships to find new routes the icebergs
along the coast of Newfoundland are
crowding popular shipping lanes and
attracting tourists who want to see them
up close the International ice Patrol
reports the number of icebergs in the
alley has tripled so far this year so we
sent Jeff Glor and he is near cape spear
in Newfoundland Jeff good morning good
morning were just off the easternmost
point of North America the Canadian
Coast Guard alone has been called 85
times this season to help ships in
trouble but this is a team effort and
the goal is to make sure those
emergencies never happen in the first
place which is why we went up with the
international ice Patrol to look for
dangers below the c-130j in hangar for
at the st. johns airport comes out only
when conditions are right in weather
beat Newfoundland and Labrador that is
not often as we boarded we saw how every
moment matters for the International ice
patrol all this weight is just
review of our population in this area
Gabrielle McGraw is the u.s. Coast Guard
commander leading the patrol coalition
of 17 nations first formed in 1913 after
the Titanic's maiden voyage was doomed
by an iceberg over the last 104 years
any vessel heating our warnings has been
safe from the danger of iceberg
collision this mission is about
identifying and tracking the biggest and
most dangerous formations which we
consider to be the driving depth of the
iceberg signals from a buoy can be
tracked immediately from the patrols
operation center in New London
Connecticut where they're handling a
fourth-straight extreme season for
icebergs 660 icebergs right now you
typically see at this time of year how
many icebergs are on average at the end
of April our numbers about 212 so around
three times three times right now
exactly with more coming down yes this
year the hulking white mountains
crowding iceberg alley' were brought in
part by two extraordinary weather
systems in late March we had a
low-pressure system that moves south of
the island of Newfoundland and it had
sustained hurricane-force winds for a
three day period that went through and
really pulled those icebergs down south
through the Labrador Current so we had
in just a week period we went from 37
icebergs in the shipping lanes up the
455 it produced spectacular images but
also loosened all this sea ice which is
clogged the world's busiest shipping
pipeline this is something our ships
have been dealing with for many years as
La Crosse as the head of marine
standards from Maersk Line we operate
big ships and an hour our Safety's
priority and hence we really try to
avoid the areas of Facebook's it is
definitely something that needs to be
considered in safe navigation the waves
of ice are crippling the fishing
business and stranding large ferries the
patrol planes can fly just hundreds of
feet above the ocean surface to give
spotters a clear view
there's also a 360 degree radar under
the nose will actually automatically
pick up target the sites can be sublime
they've drawn tourists from around the
world to this unique island province but
as commander McGraw knows the danger is
ever-present the worst case scenario
you're trying to prevent is another
Titanic exactly that's exactly right
every day that's you know that something
that we keep in our minds that ice
patrol every day is the disaster that
happened back in 1912 and we strive to
provide the best information possible on
just yesterday's flight the
international ice patrol found 382
icebergs keep in mind peak season is not
until May and June Alex Jeff Glor a
Newfoundland what internet troll oh yeah
but I'm according for duty indeed but
they look like also like great
sculptures yo they're in their massive
right fascinating footage yeah great
story